hey youtubers is Charlie so we got a
whole bunch of news about Game of
Thrones Season seven some deep cuts for
Cersei and some of the ancient Targaryen
Kings I guess we can call it deep burns
cuz of the wildfire so just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
so far so people have started to camp
this set and according to the Watchers
on the wall with some other Irish blocks
they're building around the Riverrun set
so we'll go back to Riverrun in some
small way which will loop back around
but the more important thing is that it
looks like they're building the dragon
pit which as you all know is inside
King's Landing it's one of the big
places in the city that we haven't been
yet each year as you know when they go
back to a city that they've been to in a
previous season they try to film it from
a different way give you places that you
haven't seen before just make it a
little bit more interesting this past
season we had that view of the great
Sept from the red keep when Cersei was
looking on at her trial in which she was
watching it blow up we hadn't seen that
angle of King's Landing before when you
look at the actual map of the city this
is where the dragon pit would be so this
looks like the part that they might be
building this could also double for
something else
but the idea of the dragon pit is really
important for Daenerys in the history of
King's Landing under Targaryen rule so
I'm just gonna do a quick history of the
dragon pit in King's Landing because
it's actually pretty fantastic and it's
way bigger than the great set like they
say that thirty nights riding across
from each other could all ride into the
entrance at the same time now keep in
mind that balerion the black dread the
biggest of all dragons pending how big
drogon ends up getting I don't know if
he'll outsize Beleriand eventually but
he had to live in there along with other
dragons it wasn't just balerion it was
any other dragon that happened to be
alive at the time the story of how the
dragon pit was created the reason it was
created will make a lot of sense given
what happened last season so you guys
get really excited about this so make or
the cruel just like Cersei the cruel at
the end of last season was facing a
faith militant uprising now back in the
day of maegor the cruel the big Sept of
King's Landing was called something
different and it was in a different
place it was up on this big hill right
here so as a way to put down his enemies
this is starting to sound kind of
familiar he got on balerion the black
dread and burned down that Sept with
Dragon Fire so you're like oh my god
that's the exact same thing that Cersei
did burn down the great
set to put down a faith militant
uprising so on the site of the burn set
maegor the cruel ordered that the
dragonpit be created just as a visual
reminder of what make or would do to
people who opposed him so I'm not
expecting Cersei to rebuild the dragon
pit maybe Daenerys does it eventually
but the story of maegor the cruel in the
creation of the dragon pit is just a bit
of a hat tip for Cersei the cruel in
season six in season seven going forward
however long she ends up living but what
about Daenerys and present day well it
stands reason that if they're building
this giant set that it's sometimes
Daenerys will make it to King's Landing
and when she takes the city she'll need
a place to house the dragons in the
dragon pit is designed to do exactly
that but its side note so I said you
know maegor the cruel was the one that
created the dragon pit after he blew up
the great set of his day just like
Cersei did he was succeeded by Jo Harris
the wise a lot of people felt like that
might be Jon Snow's true Targaryen name
like if Rhaegar and Lyanna maybe had
named Jon Snow they had intended the
name Jo Harris as a way to instill their
hope for his future in hit like regards
father the Mad King was terrible just
like maegor the cruel they were hoping
for a restoration after that like a
renaissance so maybe John snow was the
hopeful Jo Harris the wise come again
he had this really terrible period you
have to have a restoration so that's the
whole idea
but the biggest plot line that they have
to address in season seven is Daenerys
invasion of Westeros so in her own mind
she probably feels like she's going to
usher in this new age that's gonna be so
much better than what came before but
she still has like a little bit of the
Mad King inside her so I feel like
they're gonna flirt with the idea of Mad
Queen versus Mad Queen Cersei the cruel
versus Daenerys unburnt but let me know
in the comments what do you think
they're gonna do with the dragon pit
going forward assuming Daenerys takes
King's Landing do you think that she
would use it in the future or if she
would just outright demolish it and let
the Dragons go wherever they wanted to
the actual dragon pit itself was largely
destroyed during the dance of the
Dragons where he had two opposing
factions of the Targaryen family both on
dragon back their fight wound up to
destroying the dragonpit so we just kind
of remained in ruins hereafter until
present day but giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner William Daniels you win a $20
Amazon gift card please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details so what's
gonna happen is is I'll probably post
another bonus video in a couple days
we'll just reboot the giveaway but if
you have any requests for dragonpit
history of King's Landing history of the
Targaryen family anything you think
might be relevant to season 7 just let
me know in the comments what you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for the season 7 teaser
trailer again you can click here for Dan
and Dave's like general producers
preview of what's going on thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you